mujeres al poder en chile gabriel boric
empieza una nueva etapa como presidente
y todas las ministras y mujeres fuertes
de su futuro gabinete se han dispuesto a
llevar la lucha no solo a los despachos
sino también a las calles
emilia sneijder quien será la primera
diputada transitoria del país encabezó
la ola del feminismo de las
universidades de 2018 y ahora siendo
gobierno espera que se concreten
políticas de aborto libre y educación
sexual integral esta va a ser un
gobierno muy importante para las mujeres
y las diversidades sexuales porque ya el
gobierno ha tenido jornadas de trabajo
para transversalizar la perspectiva de
género en todas las políticas públicas
laborales económicas educativas
sanitarias el mundo empresarial ha visto
con buenos ojos el programa más moderado
de boris y a la designación de su
ministro de hacienda mario marcel un
economista con credibilidad sin embargo
para empresarios como guillermo tag el
hay otros aspectos a considerar el
factor de incertidumbre mayor es sin
duda
lo que pase durante el año 2022 con el
epílogo de la convención constituyente
eso es lo que tiene detenido en el mundo
de inversiones en muchas industrias y
mientras no se clarifique eso por qué
tipo de organización política social
económica vamos a tener es difícil que
volvamos a tener una actividad económica
normal las expectativas en todos los
sectores sociales son elevadas en este
barrio a las afueras de santiago de
población obrera como el que eligió el
nuevo presidente para vivir mirta guzmán
su hermana su hijo y la novia de éste no
esconden su entusiasmo por lo que se
viene muchísima esperanza me llega a dar
miedo toda la esperanza que él influye
yo de repente hablo con mis alumnos y
todos tienen como mucha esperanza de que
pues se puedan cambiar muchas cosas que
son muy injustas que hay en chile las
pensiones la salud la educación sistema
de la vivienda
diversidad feminismo endeudamiento
necesidad de inversión cambios sociales
las ecuaciones que se presentan ante el
nuevo gobierno de boris no tienen
resultados
los distintos sectores del país están
esperando con ansia este cambio de
mirada que se inaugura en chile
[Aplausos]